kelly fitzgibbons was one of 118 women
killed by a man over the course of 12
months in the uk
she was shot dead by her partner who
also killed their two little girls ava
who was four
and lexi who was two their three lives
were erased in a matter of seconds
i met kelly and her twin sister emma at
the youth club just there when we were
all 13.
sue redmond was kelly's best friend and
often comes to this memorial bench where
they first met as school girls
in bosom in west sussex to think about
her
it's so important purely because it's
it's raised our awareness
we had no idea until someone gave us the
heads up that
kelly's name had been read out in the
house of commons we had absolutely no
idea of the number of women
i i wouldn't even have thought there
were that many murders in the uk per
year let alone
women murdered at the hands of men it's
just truly shocking and
and it's very very right what just
phillips has done
in this place on international women's
day labor mp jess phillips read out in
parliament the names of
all the women killed by men over the
course of a year
in britain kelly fitzgibbons killed
alongside her two daughters
artist tenny beaumont saw that speech
and decided to paint a portrait
of every single woman i was obviously
hugely saddened but i was also really
shocked that actually the only name
i recognized at that point was sarah
everard
and actually she wasn't on the list yet
but she did mention her name
and it just made me think you know it
made me
curious in a way about who all these
other women were and why we didn't know
them
kelly's twin sister has set up a
charitable foundation in her name
to provide support and legal advice to
families
whose loved ones die in traumatic
circumstances
henny says the aim of her work is to
remember
honor and make all these women visible
ender brady sky news